hi friends hi food if I welcome to five
weird stuff that I found a line oh boy
oh boy do we have a great show today
let's not waste any time
I like how I couldn't even be bothered
putting the tripod up right side to sit
like fine welcome to twenty five by the
way it's all about quality the first
item is that it's another one of those
funny bacon stuff bacon is funny haha
but it is actually pretty [ __ ]
awesome look at it dis it's a bacon and
egg scarf it looks like it looks like
like I couldn't eat this I have a cold
right now so it's it's perfect for me I
can look fashionable cool and relatable
with all the men and still wear a scarf
so now I can wear at the bacon scarf and
I still look hip and cool Thank You
bacon scarf oh it even smells like bacon
no it is
number two crazy cat lady action figure
my favorite thank you so much for
suggesting this one oh look at this
comes with six cats Hey
you're kidding me let's let's open this
bad boy up
why don't I have an action figure
[ __ ] crazy cat lady gets an actually
yes lady Hey look even the arm is Bend
like that so she can hold her kitties
let me look at this kitty
this is gorgeou good Jace happy in his
mother's hand if you thought playing
with dolls was stupid this is a new low
of stupid I don't number three might say
give me this one it's very nice of her
it says I couldn't afford an expensive
present so I made one for you myself
Oh Almighty I you're so sweet that's it
Lots yeah that's a big poop I'm
impressed
wow I didn't know she had it in her
Hey number four I got from Japan I found
it in a random shop and it looks awesome
it's basically I have no idea because it
says in Japanese yeah what the [ __ ] is
this oh it comes with instructions how
great they're in Japanese
so that's great oh it kind of looks like
a golf course isn't it the [ __ ] it says
it says one thing in English and it says
may this toy give children wisdom
Oh Japan oh oh oh so it suggests that
you build like a course for the ball to
go in so this is will be the fight of
the final but I thought it would give me
the other items all right [ __ ] it I'll
build something I'll build something all
right
I built the best course ever it took me
like three hours I haven't made it work
yet but I have a good feeling oh my god
I'm gonna use my precious can it get
breath
needs more angle
okay this is it
mother
Oh
okay you're going boys
all right breasts you've waited long and
far yeah that's right I saw Jennifer
what's-her-name Aniston useless in the
YouTube video and it got like 12 million
views and I'm like I won 12 million
because it's a breast enhancer thank you
it's the most portable and simplest used
high-tech healthcare machine it's safe
and durable it invigorates health
effectively we'll see about that
that's what I am here for I'm very
excited to finally grow nice and proper
man titties all right I will now proceed
to put these on my breastesses they fit
quite nicely Oh what the [ __ ] is
happening it hurts a lot maybe I need a
broad to do a problem let's yeah can I
borrow a bra put that in there
now let's begin the breast treatment
let's start working so see my womanhood
is already coming out so this one is
supposed oh no I don't like that one the
[ __ ] who would do this so now it's
stimulating the underneath of my boobs
it's very nice product I would rate it
10 out of 10 torture machines
I've done a lot of weird [ __ ] to free
breaths this takes the [ __ ] price
alright friends that was it for 5 which
stuff with parents I hope you enjoyed I
really I think it's my favorite right
now and I think you bros like it as well
so please if you enjoyed leave a like it
really does help out a lot and suggest
me more stuff to show in five weight
stuff with boots
I appreciate if you leave Amazon links
because that makes it easier for me and
that's all for now thank you for so much
for watching and I will see you in the
next one is a brofist for you yeah
but now they